there are two
aspects of the procedure of
argumentation to which speculative
thinking is opposed
and which call for further notice first
such thinking adopts a negative attitude
towards the content it apprehends
it knows how to refute it and destroy it
that something is not the case is merely
as a merely negative insight
a dead end which does not lead to new
content beyond itself
in order to have a content once again
something new must be
taken over from elsewhere argumentation
is reflection into the empty
eye the vanity of its own its own
knowing
this vanity however expresses not only
the vanity of this content
but also the futility of this insight
itself
for this insight is the negative that
fails to see the positive within itself
because this reflection does not get its
very negativity as its content it is
never at the heart of the matter but
always beyond it
for this reason it imagines that by
establishing the void it is always ahead
of any insight rich in content
on the other hand in speculative
thinking as we've already shown
the negative belongs to the content
itself and
is the positive both is the imminent
movement
and determination of the content and as
the whole of this process
looked at as a result what emerges from
this process is the determinant negative
which is consequently a positive content
as well
section 59 begins by telling us that
there are two aspects of the procedure
of argumentation
raisoneering which speculative we've got
that up there but grife into thinking
is opposed to in which call for further
notice but then hegel goes and tells us
not just about two but about a number of
different aspects of this
so i i don't actually think it's that
helpful to try as you're reading this
this passage to figure out exactly what
the second
aspect is because there's more than one
candidate for that
he starts out saying first such
reasoning adopts a negative attitude
towards the content it
apprehends and i've got that represented
here
um argumentation raising urine is being
carried out
what does he mean by by this this term
this is a good point to pause for just a
moment
and notice that that um
what we've got here lexically
is actually sort of a german loan
word coming in from french
and you know i don't want to say in
every single case but
in many cases when you've got a a french
or latin
loanword coming in and it's being
contrasted to something that's you know
plain old german like the griff um the
german one is going to be the positive
one the one that we want
and then the other one is going to be
there's going to be something wrong with
it
and what hegel has in mind by by this is
the kind of
skeptical or constantly questioning
constantly undermining philosophy of the
french enlightenment
also the british enlightenment but not
the the
further german enlightenment
this position this position of
argumentation of reasoning
of enlightenment is always able to point
out
something wrong something
missing something negative something
lacking
in the content so like he says it takes
a negative attitude towards the
experience towards the subject matter
that's being studied
he says it knows how to refute it and
destroy it
and i think that you know we can find
plenty of philosophical attitudes in our
own time
that adopt a similar sort of perspective
if we begin from the unless you prove it
to me
by some sort of you know appeal to
philosophical intuitions or
you know what somebody said in this
article
over here that just was written 20 years
ago and we're taking as being
the hallmark for what counts as
philosophy which often happens in
analytic philosophy
we're going to reject it if we can raise
any defeaters if we can raise any
counter examples if we can
come up with any ways to parse what you
said so that it could be said a little
bit differently and there thereby wrong
then we're going to take a negative
attitude towards it and say well
it's it could be that it's actually some
some good but we can't see at this point
so we have this kind of skeptical
attitude
available in philosophy in in not just
in philosophy but but all across the
board in various uh
disciplines and institutions not just in
hegel's time but in our own time
so he's pointing something out to us he
says it takes a negative attitude
towards the content that it apprehends
it knows how to refute it how to destroy
it
that something is not the case is is a
merely negative insight though
to tell us if that's going to be what
philosophy really
is this is one reason why a lot of
people get turned off on philosophy
isn't it
because they go into a philosophy class
and they you know at least they think
they know something when they go in
and the instructor you know leads them
through some things and
we find out we don't really know what
free will is we don't really know what
you know whether we're free or not
we don't even know what determinism is
you know we can pick whatever examples
we don't know what the good
is and people come out of that and
and they're like well crap now what am i
going to do with this
and very quickly they they come to the
conclusion that well philosophy is a
fun game that you play while the
semester goes on
or you know when you've got nothing
better to do but when we actually get
out into the real world where we we do
have to make
commitments and we do need to
think in terms of content that we're not
just going to reject
then i guess philosophy is no no use to
us and
this is a position that many people
arrive at because they only encounter
this kind of thinking
so he says um
argumentation is reflection into the
empty eye
that is the the reasoning subject
i probably should have put that here
what we're talking about
is the subject who's actually carrying
this out the subject who is adopting
this critical
stance towards everything and if they
want something positive like he points
out
they've got to bring it in from the
outside what does this lead to
a merely negative insight or as he says
vanity he says
the vanity however is
the vanity is the vanity of its own
knowing
because it doesn't actually know
anything all it does is knows that
things are not the case
but it expresses not only the vanity of
this content
it turns the content into kind of a
nothing
it is never at the heart of the matter
but always
beyond it which shows us that what we're
talking about here
is a vanity or a futility
not vanity in the sense of pride but
vanity in the sense of
like in ecclesiastes vanity of vanity
all his vanities everything is
worthless everything is empty
is futile and that's all this position
can ultimately on its own provide when
it works
it works because there's something else
going on
in addition to it if you were to think
about it in recipe terms
it would be as if all you had was baking
powder you can't do much with that now
can you
add it to some other things and you can
make some interesting things happen
this is not without some value but
by itself taken as the model for
philosophy it's not it's not adequate
so he says it ends up being ahead of the
matter it's always able to say
yeah i can see that this is not going to
really work out this is not going to be
what we need
and it's it's setting itself up in this
kind of
stance for not apprehending the content
so he says speculative gyphender
thinking
uh that which uses the begriff the
concept the notion
is proceeding in a very different way
he says the negative belongs to the
content itself instead of
it bringing negation to the content
what it does is it approaches the
content it allows the content to
actually
unfold itself show its own form
and as it turns out as we've seen you
know over and over and over again
it contains negativity itself others
part of self movement is this self
othering process we don't need to go
into all that
but what he wants to get at here is by
doing that it eventually produces
a new positive content this is
actually what hegel is going to call
determinate negation
which means producing something
that's other something that's new
something that's actually
positive negation is not
purely nullifying or destroying
negation takes place by way of producing
something new something that's opposed
so
he says that looked at it as a result
what emerges from this process is the
determinant negative
which is consequently a positive content
as well
you might say well how can a negative be
a positive it depends on the
relationality how you're looking at it
in terms of the the content that you
began
with it's a negation of it and
in terms of the content that you begin
with it's also something other
something additional and in that
it is something positive and as
something positive it can become its own
content
and then it can be a negation of that
this is the way that the dialectic
proceeds
this attitude towards it can't grasp the
dialectic
as any sort of progress and it winds up
being stuck
in vanity or futility
but in view of the fact that such
thinking has a content whether of
picture thoughts or
abstract thoughts or a mixture of both
argumentation has another side which
makes comprehension difficult for it
the remarkable nature of this other side
is closely linked with the above
mentioned essence of the idea or rather
it expresses the idea in the way that it
appears as the movement
which is thinking apprehension for
whereas
in its negative behavior which we've
just discussed
racinative thinking is itself the self
which the content to which the content
returns
and it's positive cognition on the other
hand the self
is a subject to which the content is
related as
accident and predicate this
subject constitutes the basis to which
their content is attached
and upon which the movement runs back
and forth
speculative thinking behaves in a
different way
since the notion is the object's own
self which presents itself as the coming
to be of the object it is not a passive
subject
inertly supporting the accidents it is
on the contrary the self-moving notion
which takes its determinations back into
itself
in this movement the passive subject
itself perishes
it enters into the differences and the
content and
constitutes the determinateness that is
the differentiated content and its
movement instead of remaining inertly
over
against it the solid ground which
argumentation has in the passive subject
is therefore
shaken and only this movement itself
becomes the object
the subject that fills the content
ceases to go beyond it it cannot
have any further predicates or
accidental properties
conversely the dispersion of the content
is thereby
bound together under the self it is not
the universal which free from the
subject
could belong to several others
thus the content is in fact no longer a
predicate of the substance
the subject but is the substance
the essence and the notion of what is
under discussion
picture thinking whose nature it is to
run through the accidents and predicates
and which because they're nothing more
than accidents and predicates rightly
goes beyond them
is checked in its progress since that
which has the form of a predicate and a
proposition
is the substance itself it suffers as we
might put it a counter thrust
starting from the subject as though this
were a permanent ground it finds that
since the predicate is really the
substance the subject has passed over
into the predicate
and by this very fact has been sublated
and since in this way what seems to be
the predicate has become the hole in the
independent mass thinking cannot roam at
will but is impeded by this weight
usually the subject is first made the
basis as the objective fix self
thence the necessary movement to the
multiplicity of determinations or
predicate proceeds
here that subject is replaced by the
knowing i
itself which links the predicates with
the subject holding them
but since that first subject enters into
the determinations themselves and is
their soul
the second subject that is the knowing i
still finds in the predicate what it
thought it had finished with and got
away from
and from which it had hoped to return
into itself
and instead of being able to function as
the determining agent in the movement of
predication
arguing back and forth whether to attach
this or that predicate
it is really still occupied with the
self of the
content having to remain associated with
it
instead of being for itself
section 60 which is quite long also has
a lot of things going on in it there's
so to speak a lot of balls in the air
being juggled at the same time
so part of what we want to do is pay
very close attention
to what exactly is being said of what
and there's a little bit of irony in my
saying it like that because what are we
doing we're talking about you know what
is being predicated of
of what subjects in hegel's own account
we
also want to be very conscious of
which different approaches are able to
accomplish what and what they're not
able to accomplish
for the the two deficient approaches
here uh
you know argumentation or raising errand
and
picture thinking or um
for stella and we also want to
think why it is that they're they're not
able to do that
and in hegel's view this actually has to
do with
what is going on when they are thinking
their way
through the these logical categories
of subject predicate accident
what's also going on behind the scene in
terms of the
the thinking the apprehending the the
acting
subject the self the human being who's
doing this for whom
all of this stuff is
you might say out there in in the world
but also there linguistically and in
thought
you know if we want to go back this is
sort of a little digression to
aristotle's metaphysics
and categories and everything else in
between that's supposed to like lead you
from one to the other
aristotle was you know he was one of the
first thinkers to systematically grasp
and try to work out the implications
of the fact that being and thought
and language while not exactly not
exactly
coinciding or mirroring each other are
interconnected and that
the clues that are present in one help
us to better understand the other
what we do in one of these areas
modifies what's going on
in another hegel is trying to work out
this insight
and make it much more rigorous
so let's look at what he has to say
so he said he's talking still about
argumentation he says but in view of the
fact that such thinking has a content
whether picture thoughts or abstract
thoughts or a mixture both
argumentation has another subject makes
comprehension
difficult for it the remarkable nature
of this other side is closely linked
with the above mentioned essence of the
idea
rather it expresses the idea in the way
that it appears as the movement which is
thinking apprehension remember we were
talking earlier
in section uh some of the sections
preceding this
about the idea and you know
hegel backtracked that to noose and then
he
cast that back forward into the
aristotelian species or kind
or determinant universality so
how does rasa native as he's calling it
here
argumentative thinking work itself
out he says
in its positive cognition the self
is a subject to which the content is
related
as accident and predicate so
you notice i've got here subject
when we're when we're looking at a
matter and there's by the way there's
there's sort of a play on words
or deliberate equivocation intentional
ambiguity going on with this term
subject here because subject can mean
one thing in relation to accidents
another thing in relation to predicates
and another thing when we're talking
about
agency um
all of these are are wrapped up in this
and hegel is kind of playing off of
these
so he says the subject constitutes the
basis
to which the content is attached and
upon which the movement runs back and
forth
this is the way we normally think about
when we're doing say
formal logic or you know even
diagramming sentences
the way we normally think about
the relation between subjects and their
their qualities as we would say
hegel is not using that term quality
here and we'll see why
in just a few minutes
i represented this graphically for a
reason
uh when we talk about subject
in greek who pokemon uh or
in latin subjectum um
what we're thinking in terms of is
some substance some some thing
about which then we can say other things
and we can think of it in terms of the
essence of the thing
the what it is and then accidents for
example
i you know it's using a recipient
example i'm a human being
the fact that i have you know we don't
we actually say white skin but it's not
white it's pinkish
right pinkish yellowish undertone of
blue to it
brown hair a certain height these are
all things you can predicate about me
but they can also be understood as
accidents you could change those and i
could still remain the kind of being
that i am
because there's other human beings that
don't have my my skin color or
hair color or height or age or
position you know where they are they're
not on video
we can run down all these different
accidental properties and this is one
way of thinking about things these are
less
closely connected to what it what the
thing is these are
this is this is what the thing is right
now another way of thinking about it is
in terms of predicates
when we say uh greg sadler is 44 years
old which
currently is true wouldn't have been
true a month ago
we're predicating a age
a number of me and we're saying that
that's something
about what it is that i am now
when we already have in mind a given
subject and we're just sort of like
adding ideas to
it you know we've already got the
outlines we have already got
you know the thing in mind and we're
saying you know do you do i want to be a
person who's eating steak tonight or a
person who's eating potatoes tonight
those would be accidents right which we
could predict
nothing important is really going on
nothing nothing
really life-changing consciousness
changing
anything like that because we're taking
the subject
for granted as something that's known
what about when we're trying to figure
out
what is that what is the subject
how does it work is it what we think it
is
now we're dealing with something quite
different
because now the predicates really matter
a lot
and among the accidents among the things
that we can see about it
we might want to try to distinguish
which of them are actually
closer to what that thing is and if we
strip away
all of the predicates all all the
accidents what are we left with
are we left with human being or are we
left with a
sort of nothing something like an
armature just hanging there in logical
space
that's the question that hegel says
causes you know problems for reasoning
and it just goes back
and forth and back and forth why well in
part because it doesn't realize
that it itself is engaged
in this process and it also doesn't
realize
the importance
of the predicates so
what if we're doing speculative thinking
but grife into thinking what if we're
thinking things through
their notion he says since the notion is
the object's
own self which presents itself as the
coming to be
of the object it is not a passive
subject
inertly supporting the accidents it is
on the contrary
the self-moving notion which takes its
determinations
back into itself
now one way of thinking about this is
that the subject is kind of swallowing
up
all these accidents all these
predicates all the things that you can
say you know
even the relationships that it has to
other things
but another way that hegel frames it
that he focuses on here
is that the subject itself is sort of
self-giving
it is it is moving out into its
predicates he says
he says the passive subject itself
perishes
it enters into the differences and the
content this is what the content is
the the predicates so to say you know
for example
we're doing theology god is good um
god becomes sort of just a meaningless
name
until you can figure out what the hell
does good mean
and then once you start exploring that
now you actually start to know what that
is because this is sort of leeched into
its own predicates and there might be
multiple predicates
at work how can god be just and merciful
at the same time
or we can ask what is the state
or what makes things beautiful or
what's going on in this particular kind
of music
and we begin with a subject then we
start predicating
and the subject by a kind of
intellectual osmosis or self-donation
becomes its predicates so he says
the subject that fills its content
ceases to go beyond it and cannot have
any further predicates or accidental
properties we start to realize the what
it is
by grasping things in terms of
quality not in terms of substance or
being
or subject apart from quality
but we grasp quality as
having an ultimate metaphysical priority
over any other determination that we
would like to think of
place time uh agency passivity all these
other categories
including number quantity and including
substance usia in in the the classic
uh aristotelian texts so he says
the passive the the solid ground which
argumentation has in the past
subject is therefore shaken only the
movement itself becomes the
object so he says the dispersal
of the dispersion of the content is
thereby bound together under the self
it is not the universal which free from
the subject could belong to several
others
the content is in fact no longer a
predicate of the substance
the subject but is the substance
it is the concept
the predicate is where the side of the
concept
is
the notion he says picture thinking
likes to
understand things just by looking at all
the accidents or predicates
and sort of you know helps to sketch
them in sort of like color by numbers
it doesn't know what to do with this
here
says that which has the form of a
predicate and a proposition
is the substance itself it suffers as we
might put it a counter thrust
starting from the subject as though this
were a permanent ground which which it's
not
that's the thing what gives the subject
its permanent ground is the
person the thinker
who is apprehending this
all of this is taking place for
and in consciousness and in this process
consciousness is coming to know what
the thing in its concept or notion
truly is in relation to to itself so he
says
uh it finds that since the predicate is
really the substance the subject is
passed
over into the predicate by this very
fact has been
sublated so what we have going on here
is actually the process of
what hegel calls
alphabone we translate that in english
as sublation
and that means the development of
something through negation into
something else something different
something greater something that
includes and incorporates it we can
think of this in terms of
the development of shapes of
consciousness of the gestalton
through the dialectical process the the
new one that develops
incorporates much of what has gone
before at least an outline
but sort of leaves behind the detritus
this also happens
at the level of subject predicate logic
hegel would say if we're following the
speculative process so
pleasure is the good
what's going on there the classic
statement of hedonism right
should we regard it in terms of pleasure
being the subject and it has the
quality of being the good but then
perhaps we should actually turn it
around maybe the good
is pleasure
and one you know if we follow this out
we're not going to try to do that right
now
we could follow this out and look at it
dialectically and we would find that
not only can pleasure be understood as
something good
not only can the good be understood as
pleasure but also all sorts of
openings to the negative are going to
occur in this as well where we have to
say but wait a second
aren't there good and bad pleasures the
dialectic that
for example gets carried out in uh
plato's
works or aerosols works in any case he
says
it's been sublated and since in this way
what seems to be the predicate has
become the hole in the independent mass
thinking cannot roam at will but is
impeded
by this weight so we see that two
different kinds
of thinking that we've now talked about
quite a bit
raison urine uh you know argumentative
rationative
thinking which doesn't actually have
a foundation for itself but is sort of a
loose free activity
which unfortunately lapses into vanity
as a result
and can't handle a dialectical approach
to subject predicate
accident those sorts of things on the
one hand
on the other hand picture thinking for
sheldon
uh you know wanting to imagine
everything in terms of
images in terms of things that it can
wrap its its head around
and its eyes around and its hands around
and say
things can only really be this way both
of those are going to be stymied
by what what's speculative or
dialectical the gryffindor
working with the concept the notion the
griff
thinking actually does so hegel is
trying to caution us
at this point against lapsing back into
those not deficient
uh in all cases but deficient in this
case modes of thought